foreign
on the front lines of the war in Ukraine
you might not expect to find a rabbi
dear friends now we go to say to save
people that's waiting fast Moshe Osmond
is Ukraine's Chief Rabbi he's traversing
the country delivering Aid and
evacuating civilians swapping his Jewish
kippa and Kittle for a helmet and flak
jacket and for good reason
on a recent trip to the flooded city of
her son a Russian shell landed nearby
fortunately no one was hurt the Russians
Russian army they shelling to the
civilian people for the evacuation
missions Osman was born in Russia and
moved to Kiev 30 years ago with his
Ukrainian wife in 2015 he opened this
Refugee Center for ukrainians fleeing
the fighting in the donbass
when Russia invaded last year his
Refugee Center became a bomb shelter
that's why I was very nervous because I
helped many people as women children my
children was there and my
grandchildren's small grandchildren when
the bombs finally stopped hours later
Osmond recorded this video for Facebook
speaking Russian and cradling a Torah
scroll he condemned the Russian people
the video was viewed nearly a million
times so the rabbi recorded another and
another Before the War I was a very
quiet guy I cannot be now quiet his
viral videos are recorded in Russian
Ukrainian and English calling for
support from the West
Osmond visited Canada this week after
earlier trips to Israel the UK and the
US meeting with Ukrainian and Jewish
Community groups it is very important to
spread the word of Truth and saying the
Jews and ukrainians are together this
expert in Jewish Ukrainian relations
says some in the Jewish Community remain
divided over support for Ukraine the
rabbi has very good influence people and
he can convince and explain for
Ukrainian Jews Putin's false claim about
liberating the country from Nazis is
particularly hard to stomach what's your
reaction to that don't use it what do
you say Ukrainian the Nazis we don't
have nothing in Ukraine please don't
make speculation of the tragedy of
Jewish people now he says it's not the
Nazis but the Russians killing Jewish
people Jeff sample Global News Toronto